[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo dernier numéro de cette
session extraordinaire et dernier numéro
de la saison 26 minutes pour revenir sur
l'actualité de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat et cette semaine notre invité
est le député rassemblement national
julien rul bonjour bonjour et c'est
katia qu'il a brossé votre portrait
bonjour tam bonjour julien odoul votre
portrait en quelques traits de plume
vous êtes un nouveau député vous avez
été élu dans l'yonne vous êtes historien
de formation à 20 ans vous soutenez
laurent fabius à la primaire socialiste
de 2006 on vous retrouve ensuite chez
les centristes au nouveau centre puis à
lui dis parce que vous êtes un proche
d'andré santini à l'époque en 2014 voilà
au front national puis au rassemblement
national de marine le pen dont vous êtes
un proche est ce qu'aujourd'hui génère
12 vous avez trouvé votre parti
politique bon ça fait huit ans que je
suis engagé auprès de marine le pen pour
les idées nationales c'est le seul parti
auquel finalement j'ai adhéré par
conviction et surtout j'ai participé à
des élections donc je suis traité
non non j'ai voté à la primaire de 2006
parce que j'avais envie de m'engager
démocratiquement et moi je suis un
traumatisé de 2002 puisque j'avais 17
ans à l'époque et je n'avais pas pu
participer à cette échéance majeure il
fait c'était dans l'entre-deux-tours
contre jean-marie
suis jamais caché je m'en suis jamais
caché c'était une période très
différente jean marie le pen j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour son combat
politique pour autant marine le pen a
donné une autre dimension au front
national lui a donné sur la
professionnalisation non non non
j'aurais pas adhérer à son parti parce
que je ne voyais pas la finalité en tout
cas je ne voyais pas le projet politique
marine le pen m'a convaincu que l avait
à coeur de défendre les français en
gagnant pouvoir tout simplement en
mettant nos idées au pouvoir c'est toute
la différence entre un parti de
contestation parti d'opposition est
aujourd'hui un parti gouvernement est
devenu notre parti vous vous vous
assumez la ligne vous êtes vous de
partir là bas je pense qu après huit ans
de cartes après des élections
divers élections auxquelles j'ai pu
participer après diverses campagnes
après mes engagements différents et
aujourd'hui ce mandat de député oui je
pense que je suis fidèle ou rassemble
nationale et je suis fier de faire
partie de cet alibi le rassemblement
national va se chercher pour la première
fois un président de parti qui n'est pas
issu de la famille le pen alors vous
êtes plutôt jordan bardella ou louis
aliot moi je souhaite que jordan
bardella soit le prochain président du
rassemblement national
il a effectué ces derniers mois ces
dernières années un boulot considérable
dans la ligne de marine le pen il nous a
extrêmement aider sur le volet de la
professionnalisation de donner une image
extrêmement positive à notre mouvement a
contribué aux victoires de la
présidentielle avec ce score historique
et avec les 89 députés à l'assemblée
nationale donc je considère que c'est le
meilleur pour nous permettre de franchir
la dernière marche est d'arriver au
pouvoir en 2027 est ce que ce n'est pas
marine le pen qui même si elle va être
présidente du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale qui reste la cheffe de tout on
a plus l'impression que c'est une pme
familiale on l'a souvent dit que le
rassemblement national mais au fond ça
reste quand même elle la chef non marine
le pen est la chef de l'opposition
nationale les français l'ont souhaité à
l'élection présidentielle les français
ont souhaité aussi qu'elle préside le
premier groupe d'opposition au parlement
donc tout ça c'est juste c'est une
logique que marine le pen contribue
aussi et continue et la forte en les
idées nationale laissant les clés du
coup un gendarme bardé la police ne fait
pas laisser les clés vous savez nous
sommes un grand parti un grand parti
démocratique il ya un congrès il y aura
une élection
hélas aujourd'hui nous avons deux outils
extraordinaires pour défendre les
français c'est à dire à la fois le
groupe à l'assemblée nationale avec ses
89 députés avec une force de frappe
parlementaires importantes et puis le
parti qui je l'espère sera présidée par
jordan dans quelques semaines alors on
va dérouler la semaine avec vous julien
odoul avec d'abord la bataille du
pouvoir d'achat au sénat la droite
sénatoriale entend libérer le travail
réclament la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte
mais veut plus des aides pour les
collectivités en raison de l'explosion
des dépenses liées à l'énergie on
reviendra sur la mise au point de bruno
le maire lors de la discussion à
l'assemblée nationale du volet
budgétaire de ces mesures le ministre a
reproché à certains députés de faire
monter la facture du budget en vo
tenteront de nouvelles dépenses
et puis on fera le bilan d'un mois de
travail parlementaire on verra quels
sont les principaux rapports de force et
politiques entre les oppositions et le
gouvernement qui dispose d'une majorité
relative il y a beaucoup d'ambiance au
parlement
et on commence avec l'examen des mesures
d'urgence pour le pouvoir d'achat au
sénat la droite critiquent veut imprimer
sa marque au texte valeur travail
économie sauf pour les collectivités
pour lesquelles elle réclame plus dead
jeunes attendus priest
après d'âpres débats au palais bourbon
le marathon sur le texte pouvoir d'achat
se poursuit au sénat la droite
majoritaire au palais du luxembourg veut
imprimer sa marque en modifiant des
dispositions sur le travail les aides
aux collectivités tout en maîtrisant le
quoi qu'il en coûte d'un texte à 20
milliards d'euros beaucoup d articles du
projet de loi transmis au sénat la
semaine dernière composer un ensemble
hétéroclite notre commission a souhaité
le modifier en partant d'un principe
simple apporter une réponse immédiate et
concrète aux difficultés de nos
concitoyens face à l'inflation tout en
privilégiant à cette fin la valorisation
du travail si elle ne se fait aucune
illusion la gauche veut aussi avoir son
mot à dire le groupe socialiste plaide
notamment pour une revalorisation du
smic à 1500 euros net et s'offusque
surtout du triplement de la prime macron
une prime que les entreprises peuvent
verser à leurs employés jusqu'à 6000
euros défiscalisées cette prime cieux
ministre si je vous pensais naïve
pourrait être qualifié de fausse bonne
idée mais vous n'êtes pas naïf je crois
aux contrats que ce dispositif est la
traduction concrète de l'idéologie
néolibérale qui vous anime toujours
néfaste pour les salariés toujours
profitable pour le patronat les
communistes dénoncent des mesurettes du
gouvernement pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français il propose donc des solutions
plus radicales comme taxer les super
profits des grandes entreprises afin de
financer un nouveau bouclier social face
à la montée des prix de l'essence dédale
des denrées alimentaires des loyers des
transports le gouvernement a décidé de
répondre pas départ des mesurettes qui
ne remettent absolument pas en question
le choix de fond que sont les cadeaux
aux plus grandes entreprises une
proposition irréaliste pour le
gouvernement immédiatement balayé par le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
vous pouvez vous faire plaisir en
réclamant des taxes mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
moi je préfère faire plaisir à nos
compatriotes en obtenant des remises qui
vont directement dans leurs poches
plutôt que dans la poche du trésor
public fait rare le groupe centriste
allié de l erp au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale se désolidarise de la droite
sur cette question des superprofits les
centristes défendent d'une taxation des
grandes entreprises pour équilibrer les
comptes de l'état
alors la droite a donc déjà à modifier
les contours de la prime pouvoir d'achat
elle a également voté la baisse des
cotisations patronales sur les heures
sup elle n'a pas baissé la
revalorisation du rsa comme le
souhaitait la droite sénatoriale
quelques modifications seulement
faudrait que c'est difficile de pas
voter un texte de cadeaux difficile de
s'y opposer
difficile de s'y opposer oui parce que
même si les mesures sont insuffisantes
même si les dispositifs sont un parfait
c'est une aide ponctuelle qui donnait
aux français et la situation de
compatriotes est tellement alarmante
qu'aujourd'hui il faut voter ce texte il
faut voter ces dispositifs nous avons
fait d'autres choix nous avons proposé
au gouvernement notamment une baisse
drastique de taxes rentrer de l'argent
français avec la tva sur les produits
énergétiques la faire passer de 20% à 5
5 ce qui rendrait automatiquement 150
euros à 200 euros de pouvoir d'achat par
mois à chaque ménage nous avons demandé
aussi que 100 produits de première
nécessité d'alimentation et d'hygiène
est une tva à taux zéro pour aider les
quatre et on n'a pas été écouté pour
ronan vous inspire une exposition
responsables et nous considérons que
tout ce qui peut être que pris tout ce
qui peut être gagnée pour le
portefeuille des français doit l'être et
donc en responsabilité nous avons fait
le choix de soutenir ces mesures même si
elles sont insuffisantes et un parallèle
bruno retailleau a demandé au
gouvernement de se serrer un peu la
ceinture est ce que vous redoutez que le
texte qui a examiné au sénat et celui de
ne sortent pas du tout comme celui de
l'assemblée qu'il ya une différence de
texte ne soit pas du tout la même
version que les députés ont voté je
pense que les différences seront minimes
malheureusement je dirais nous aurions
souhaité véritablement un choc pour le
pouvoir de vivre parce que la situation
je les jeux les 10es cataclysmique pour
des millions de français et on a vu
notamment lors des débats que le
gouvernement prend un petit peu à la
légère on a eu des débats qui était géré
un petit peu à côté de l'urgence sociale
et qui ne correspondent pas
quelquefois hors sujet effectivement on
a eu beaucoup de débats qui concernait
la transition énergétique
on a eu beaucoup de débats qui ne visait
pas tout simplement améliorer comprendre
la transition énergétique par rapport à
ce qui se prépare
à toutes les sauces alors qu'aujourd'hui
à des français qu'ils ne peuvent plus se
déplacer des français qui ne peuvent
plus se nourrir parce que les prix sont
devenus tellement haut que encore une
fois leur et stages à vivre s'est
effondré je considère qu'il y avait
d'autres choix à faire plus la fin du
monde et la fin du mois non je pose pas
moi vous savez y ait des priorités moi
je veux bien effectivement que les
français fassent des efforts ils en font
depuis des années sur la transition
énergétique sur des normes sur des taxes
et cetera aujourd'hui il faut que l'état
fasse des efforts l'état n'a jamais fait
d'effort justement pour rendre de
l'argent mais avec une telle taxe il
faudra bien payer alliés des économies à
faire vous savez j'ai fait tous les
économies on les fait notamment sur la
fraude sociale la fraude sociale vous le
savez au sénat ait eu des rapports qui
était assez éloquent sur le sujet ça
représente entre 15 milliards d'euros et
45 milliards d'euros par an les
gouvernements successifs ne sont jamais
allés chercher cette fraude sociale ya
des économies à faire sur l'immigration
sur les contributions d'accord avec du
coup la majorité sénatoriale qui va qui
préparent des amendements notamment au
budget rectificatif sur ce sujet mais je
place je vais
avec gouvernement partent en croisade
pour récupérer cet argent qui est volé
chaque année aux contribuables français
et qui permettrait justement
d'accompagner ces baisses de taxes et de
rendre cet argent aux français qui n'est
pas de l'argent perdu quand vous rendez
150 euros à 200 euros de pouvoir d'achat
par mois à chaque ménage mais c'est de
l'argent qui est réinjecté dans la
consommation qui a injecté pour les
ménages qui par exemple ne vont pas se
mettre en arrêt maladie parce qu'ils
pourront aller travailler c'est de
l'argent utile pour les français une
autre source possible de subsides un
bien c'est la taxe sur les super-profits
on a entendu à bruno le maire qui s'y
est opposé à l'assemblée comme au sénat
il dit je préfère négocier avec total
tout de suite pour obtenir à 20 centimes
de ristournes plutôt qu'enrichir le
trésor public c'est un argument qui sont
en haut oui monsieur le maire en fait tu
ne veux jamais taxer ceux qui profitent
des crises monsieur le maire en fait
toujours dans cette illusion
avec des garanties sauf que les
garanties de monsieur le maire ne
garantit jamais rien on l'avait vu
notamment dans la sphère de general
electric on le voit aussi maintenant
avec total effectivement il ya des gens
et des institutions et gad et comment
dirais-je des entreprises qui ont
profité de la crise mais qui profitent
toujours d'accéder vous êtes d'accord
avec votre collègue de la lutte qui
parle des profiteurs de crise il faut
taxer mais bien sûr qu'il faut c'est
pour ça que nous avons demandé nous
aussi une commission d' enquête sur
l'inflation pour voir qui a profité de
la crise pour quoi nous avons cette
inflation qui n'est pas dû seulement à
la guerre en ukraine puisque je vois que
le gouvernement se retranche derrière la
guerre en ukraine la hausse des prix ça
a commencé bien avant la guerre en
ukraine que ce soit sur les produits
énergétiques que ce soit sur les
produits de première nécessité donc il
faut effectivement que ceux qui ont
profité de la crise rendent aussi de
l'argent mais l'état déjà profité de la
crise avec la tva parce que à chaque
fois que les prix augmentent la tva
augmente c'est vrai des rentrées
d'argent pour l'état un tout dernier mot
sur la différence d'ambiance entre les
deux chambres 1 au sénat les débats vont
assez vite on sent que certaines
négociations en amont des a eu lieu à
l'assemblée les débats ont été beaucoup
plus long beaucoup plus électrique à
dire que finalement ça va être au sénat
que ça va être plus simple pour le
gouvernement de travailler est ce que
c'est là que va finir par se fabriquer
la loi oui mais c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui a le dernier mot voilà
donc désolé pour nos collègues sénateurs
si un actif
bien sûr comment
les ambiance totalement différente à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons
quasiment une assemblée à la
proportionnelle ce qui change tout c'est
les français qui l'ont voulu qu'ils ont
imposée lors des dernières élections
législatives donc la culture ne va pas
être la même effectivement au sénat vous
n'avez pas tous les courants toutes les
opinions qui sont représentés nous
pouvons déplorer d'ailleurs nous
espérons en france à avoir des sénateurs
dans quelques mois mais très clairement
l'assemblée nationale c'est
véritablement le coeur battant de la
démocratie parce que toutes les idées
toutes les opinions peuvent être
défendus et représentait alors à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement a
essuyé plusieurs revers pendant l'examen
du budget rectificatif qui comprend
notamment le deuxième volet de mesures
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat le
ministre des finances a reproché aux
députés de voter des amendements coûteux
pour les finances publiques écoutez
bruno le maire j'ai dit depuis le début
depuis le début de l'examen de ce plfr
qu'il fallait garder l'équilibré entre
ce qui était nécessaire pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes et
bien nous sommes en train de dériver
vers la compensation des collectivités
locales qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes et
la maîtrise des finances publiques je
redis à quel point j'ai juste eu préfet
stupéfait de voir les parlementaires qui
sur les plateaux de télévision à
longueur d'interviews donc que le mot
rétablissement des finances publiques à
la bouche qui engage telle dépense
publique
est ce que bruno le maire a raison de
vouloir modérée la dépense publique ça
va coûter cher toutes ces mesures vous
avez dit comment voulait financer mais
ça suffira peut-être pas il a raison
c'est vrai que les leçons de monsieur le
maire on s'en passerait bien parce que
quand on a le bilan de ce gouvernement
la fois sur le volet économique et
social je dire vaut mieux se taire au
mieux se taire 6,6 milliards d'euros de
dettes notamment on a six millions de
chômeurs le chômage n'a jamais baissé
notre pays nonobstant la propagande du
gouvernement
nous avons dîné quand même une
amélioration
je ne conteste pas si je les regarde si
on en croit les derniers chiffres nous
avons en catégorie ya 3 millions 165
mille chômeurs catégories a b c nous
avons 5 millions 4 le chômeur et si on a
les deux autres catégories parce que le
gouvernement oublie qu'elle est
catégories d et e on à 350 mille
chômeurs environ par catégorie ça nous
fait 6 millions de chômeurs le chômage
n'a jamais baissé depuis que monsieur
macron est arrivé aux manettes il faut
dire que ce que lorsqu'ils disent que le
chômage s'est améliorée il joue avec
giroud là mais en fait ils considèrent
que les chômeurs sont uniquement ceux
qui sont en catégorie à or aujourd'hui
nous avons six millions de français qui
sont en insécurité sociale et
professionnelle par calcul est bien
évidemment qui cherchent un emploi en
permanence tout simplement est ce qu'il
faut abandonner le quoi qu'il en coûte
pour vous il faut rétablir notamment le
quoi qu'il en coûte pour aider les
français qui n'en peuvent plus à vivre
dignement c'est tout aujourd'hui on a
une politique qui fragilise le coût pour
les finances publiques mais on a quand
même un plan à 20 milliards y'a encore
aux 350 millions que les nominés var
jambes remplissent à l'assemblée
nationale on est pareil et on attend on
attend leurs on attend le renommé sco ce
qu'on reproche à ce gouvernement c'est
qu'il ne fait pas des économies dans des
domaines qui aujourd'hui sont superflus
et qui notamment gaspille l'argent
public j'ai parlé de la fraude sociale
je peux parler de l'immigration je peux
parler notamment de toute la gabegie
tout cet argent qui est aujourd'hui
dédié à des cabinets conseils étrangers
comme mckinsey donc j'observe que le
gouvernement veut continuer à engraisser
ces cabinets conseils entre
ce qui est assez choquant c'est six
nations dans la nuit l'eau d'autres
l'autre soir il a rayé d'un trait de
plume donc les 500 millions que nous
souhaitions accordée pour le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités mais aussi
conseil étrangers de revenir sur un vote
c'est là c'est la seconde délibération à
le fait que le gouvernement demande à
revoter sur une mesure c'est son droit
qui est prévu par la procédure
parlementaire a crié certains dans
l'opposition au déni de démocratie mais
c'est pas le cas mais c'est peut-être
légal mais ce n'est pas moral déjà et je
considère que c'est une très fréquemment
je considère que c'est une faute grave
qui fait aujourd'hui trois perdants
premiers perdants sont évidemment les
retraités les retraités qui pâtissent de
l'augmentation des prix de l'inflation
et qui aurait bien aimé avoir cette
revalorisation de leurs pensions de
retraite de 500 millions d'euros qui
avait été voté par l'assemblée nationale
dans un premier temps ensuite ensuite
ils interagissent bien qu'il ya un
deuxième perdant il ya un deuxième
perdants ce sont les électeurs aient
l'air parce que heller a changé son vote
entre 18 heures et 2 heures du matin il
faut bien le dire donc aujourd'hui vous
avez des ailes à des parisiens qui font
partie de la majorité présidentielle qui
ont intégré la macro n'y sont plus de
facto non bien sûr que non ils se sont
soumis à la macro dit d'ailleurs on
aimerait bien savoir quel a été l'objet
du marchandage parce qu'une négociations
de couloir s'est offert et aussi bien
sûr bien sûr parce que c'est de la
vieille politique parce que c'est tout
ce qui dégoûte les français et je
considère que ce n'est pas démocratique
d'ailleurs ce qui se dessinait en est
ensuite allé ensuite il ya un troisième
perdant si vous me le permettez c'est
effectivement la nouvelle méthode du
gouvernement qui effectivement est
pulvérisé par cette volonté du
gouvernement de passer en force a fait
qu'ils n'acceptent pas d'être mis en
minorité
non bien sûr que non ce sont des
éléments de langage et on voit bien dans
les débats que le gouvernement fait n'a
pas pris la mesure de ce qui s'est passé
aux élections législatives ne supporte
pas d'avoir la majorité relative ne
supporte pas que les oppositions pèse
plus lourd à l'assemblée nationale et ne
supporte pas de ne pas pouvoir passer
tous ses textures des revers le
gouvernement sur d'autres comme louis
oui bien sûr mais on
mais en fait je n'ai pas du tout
compromis il n'accepte aucun amendement
du rassemblement national il n'y a
aucune discussion n'a aucune volonté d'
écoute il ya des ligands promis
soit disant de ne faisons pas partie de
l'arc républicain alors nous avons été
lus par des millions de français que
nous sommes élus du peuple comme les
autres donc très clairement entre les
mots et les actes il ya un gouffre il ya
un océan même et qui a pas de nouvelles
méthodes du gouvernement il ya juste la
volonté de passer en force comme ça a
été le cas pour les pensions de retraite
le sénat veut aller plus loin que la
semblait un peu plus loin que les 300
millions d' aide aux collectivités vous
y est favorable il faut la compensation
intégrale de la hausse du point d'indicé
sac là ça serait un milliard de plus ça
c'est pas possible non mais il faut
aider les collectivités parce qu'on n'en
parle pas assez qu'ils vont être
extrêmement impacté par l'inflation moi
j'ai des exemples dans ma
circonscription de communes voilà qui
ambitionne kif dans l'yonne exactement
troisième circonscription de l'yonne qui
voient leurs charges explosent et que ce
soit évidemment pour le point d'indicé
que ce soit pour les dépenses de gaz
d'énergie d'électricité tout ça
évidemment va peser lourd dans le budget
des communes et surtout bien sûr parce
qu'il ne faut pas laisser les communes
augmenter les impôts parce que ça va
être ça la conséquence augmenter les
impôts parce qu'elles ne pourront pas
s'en sortir autrement il faut que ce
soit compensé par l'état
alors on va passer à la suite le
parlement élu le 19 juin a entamé ses
travaux il est un peu plus d'un mois
julien odoul vous travaillé
d'arrache-pied privé de majorité le
gouvernement pourtant comme on l'a dit
doit composer discuter négocier avant la
discussion de chaque projet de loi
stéphanie des pierres nous fait un
premier bilan politique de ce début de
session premier projet de loi et premier
coup de théâtre le 13 juillet en pleine
nuit les députés supprime l'article 2
sur le passé ni terreau frontières pour
195 contre 219 une coalition inédite de
là nous pèse du rassemblement national
et des républicains vient de battre le
gouvernement habituez vous à ce que le
parlement fonctionne comme ça habituez
vous à ce que nous allions jusqu'au bout
de nos propositions
dorénavant la majorité va devoir écouter
elles n'y étaient pas habitués va devoir
composer va devoir respecter ou sinon
elle devra revoir sans arrêt sa copie
une nouvelle ère où la majorité n'est
que relative et où les insoumis et le
rassemblement national se disputent le
rôle de premier opposant vélo et rennes
votre un finalement pour le premier
volet du paquet pouvoir d'achat pas la
vitesse nous vous proposons ici
simplement de manière formelle de
renommée l'article pour être peut-être
plus cohérent avec son contenu en
l'intitulant prime enfumage vous n'êtes
pas là pour faire avancer le pouvoir
d'achat vous êtes là pour faire un petit
jeu avec le roi macro vous êtes les
bouffons rose du roi macron au fil des
séances on soufflera sur tous les bancs
rappel au règlement incident suspension
multiples arrêter ce cirque les débats
s'éternisent et le ministre de
l'économie s'énerve à propos d'une
discussion sur les pompiers n'ont
vacciné ça n'est pas le débat de la loi
pouvoir d'achat donc évitons ces
dévoiements démocratique revenons à ce
qui est le coeur d'autres discussions le
pouvoir d'achat y a aucune volonté de
blocage ici juste une volonté
d'argumenter et nous allons continuer à
argumenter et si vous considérez que ça
prend trop de temps et bah ça prendra le
temps qu'il faut pas ce que c'est les
priorités des françaises et des français
en coulisses le gouvernement négocie
avec les républicains qui obtiennent
notamment l'augmentation du rabais sur
l'essence parce que nous voulons être
utile aux français nous voterons donc ce
plfr qu'il va participer au pouvoir
d'achat des français malgré d'importants
revers le gouvernement réussit à faire
passer ses trois premier texte à
l'assemblée désormais pour chaque projet
de loi la bataille parlementaire
s'annonce intense
tu dis en doute le gouvernement ne peut
s'appuyer que sur une majorité relative
à l'assemblée mais les oppositions même
si elles sont importantes sont pourtant
divisée bref sans majorité ni les
personnes ni possibilité d'union durable
est ce que le parlement pour vous est
vraiment mission de force il n'y a pas
un risque de blocage le parlement a
retrouvé sa vocation déjà on n'y était
plus habitué mais les cinq dernières
années le parlement l'assemblée
nationale était devenu une chambre
d'enregistrement
c'est à dire que monsieur macron appuyer
sur un bouton vous aviez sa horde
députés qui se levait qui
applaudissaient et qui votait n'y avait
pas de débat et d'ailleurs c'est un
problème démocratique les français
d'ailleurs l'ont exprimé avec la crise
des gilets jaunes ils voulaient la
proportionnelle monsieur mâcon n'a
jamais voulu la voter n'a jamais voulu
donc instituée une dose de
proportionnelle les français l'ont
imposé par le vote aux élections
légistatives donc ça redonne du crédit
du sens et de l'importance du poids
politique même à l'assemblée nationale
et donc à la représentation nationale
soit quand même des débats houleux
dispersé c'est normal non mais c'est
normal moi je préfère que les jeux non
non je préfère que les débats soient
houleux au sein de l'hémicycle plutôt
qu'il soit ou le et fracturés dans la
rue je considère que c'est sain que les
clivages politiques s'expriment au sein
de l'assemblée nationale alors oui à des
divergences profondes oui à peut-être
une ambiance qui déplaît à la majorité
parce qu'ils n'y sont pas habitués mais
je trouve que jusqu'à présent il n'y a
pas eu de dérapage depuis que la statue
des provocations de l'extrême gauche
nubes qui fait du cirque permanent
pathmanathan
fachos voulait traiter de bouffon rouge
de mâcon on l'a aussi entendu c'est
agréable ces bouffons rejoint
la réalité en fait ça correspond
notamment à leur pratique de l'orme en
bien des invectives des deux côtés il
n'y a pas que la france un swing ans
mais il n'ya pas d'invectivés du côté du
race moyenne nous sommes une opposition
sérieuse responsable constructive nous
avons montré tout au long des débats que
nous ne pouvions servir guy par exemple
on va voir enfin arriver
aujourd'hui est une personnalité de
l'assemblée nationale qui fait honneur à
notre groupe et à notre mouvement c'est
une inde et put est extrêmement
compétent notamment sur les sujets
budgétaire et financier promena type
d'énergie également et je trouve que
c'est bien qu'elle l'assemblée nationale
et des personnalités qui s'expriment
justement pour porter la voix du peuple
et pour porter une autre voie ce que les
français finalement détestait ces
dernières années pourquoi il s'est
déroulé de la politique parce que
finalement le parlement ne servait à
rien il n'aura su ce mythe mais je
voulais vous poser cette question autour
du fait que le rassemblement national
doit déposer plainte pour le salut nazi
d'un député renaissance qui a écopé lui
d'un rappel à l'ordre qui avaient dit
avoir fait ce geste pour avertir que
l'un des membres de votre groupe l'avait
lui-même fait ou est ce que vous en êtes
de ça déjà c'est une diffamation nous
nous allons porter plainte effectivement
je considère que c'est une honte et
c'est un scandale que monsieur
rebeyrotte parce qu'il faut les nommer
député macro ni de saône et loire n'est
pas été sanctionné par l'international
ça n'est jamais arrivé ça n'est jamais
arrivé en fait dans l'histoire de la
république qu'un député fasse un salut
nazi au sein de l'hémicycle c'est une
honte est une insulte pour nos 13
millions d'électeurs et je considère
qu'il aurait dû être sanctionné voire
même de démissionner parce que c'est
infamant et des grands demandé sa
démission bien sûr ils venaient de
questions sur votre position vous dit
vous êtes constructif mais peut-être pas
toujours parce que vous avez voté le
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat vous êtes
abstenu sur le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif c'est un peu en concours
d'un cohérence avec les élèves parfois
aussi non c'est pas c'est pas du tout un
concours d'incohérente nous avons jugé
que les mesures urgentes au pouvoir
d'achat devait être voté pour aider nos
compatriotes parce que notre seule
boussole c'est l'intérêt national donc
vous voter en fonction en fonction de
l'intérêt national chez nous c'est très
simple nous sommes élus par le peuple et
nous considérons que si ça améliore le
pouvoir d'achat si ça renforce sa
sécurité si ça reste or la grandeur
notre pays nous l'accompagnons en
revanche si s'est opposé aux intérêts
nationaux et si c'est contre le peuple
français nous y opposons farouchement
merci je les andouilles d'allah est
l'invité de parlement hebdo le dernier
parlement hebdo de la saison tam et le
dernier parlement hebdo pour moi puisque
vous retrouvez bien la saison prochaine
à ma place alexandre poussin pour public
sénat alexandre pouchard qu'on le
retrouvera donc à la rentrée dès le 23
septembre merci à tous ciao
[Musique]